hey everybody I'm Larry here Xbox Live's
Major Nelson I'm here today with Scott
Henson from the Xbox engineering team to
talk about some new features coming to
Xbox one Scott great to have you it's
great to be here Larry
now the creators update is scheduled to
release for everyone in the spring and
today the first wave of Xbox preview
members will get a sneak peek in the
weeks ahead more and more Xbox insider
program members will receive the new
features let's take a look at what's new
Scott what is the theme of today's Xbox
insider release now the creators update
in general is really about performance
it's about people it's about competition
and it's about streaming right so right
now people are gonna be able to play
with a lot of those features as a part
of the insider program so for example
one of the things that we've done is
we've redesigned the guide to get to you
the most common tasks that you perform
every single day one button press and
all those common tasks are always
available to you we've also streamlined
home so that the things that you're
playing contextually related to that
show up around that game and all of our
multitasking system is now redesigned
around the guide itself Scott there's
some big changes here so what's gonna
happen now when I hit the Xbox Guide
button on my controller so no matter
what you're doing whether you're playing
a game or watching Netflix or what have
you you'll hit that button and you'll
have a whole world of instantly
accessible features you'll be able to go
to home you'll be able to get to my
games and apps be able to get to the
store of course you're able to get back
to the game or the thing that you were
running your recently run activities
will be instantly accessible to you and
at the bottom will be the pins now if
you're playing background music right
there on that home page you'll be able
to pause fast-forward and change the
volume on that as well in addition to
that multitasking feature we've got
instant access to the achievement
tracker
we've got instant access to game DVR and
of course what everyone's excited about
is very quick access to be able to
become a broadcaster as well
now Scott one feature I'm really excited
about is you did some work around the
game DVR so now with a one button I now
have access to I won our cork last 15
seconds 30 seconds one minute and so
forth it's all right there on the guy
that's right and of course you can also
start a recording or take a screenshot
as well Scott tell us about the work the
team has done around broadcasting and
we've actually done quite a bit to make
that super simple both on the console as
well as on Windows 10 pcs on the console
we're using that guide again as the
multitasking Center where you'll be able
to instantly get into being broadcast by
selecting the broadcast icon now this
isn't available immediately but will be
available in the weeks to come
now of course lots of people continue to
stream on Twitch that will continue to
work that will continue to be a great
experience on the console and we're
excited about that as well the team has
also done some work around Cortana tell
us about that well we've gotten lots of
feedback on Cortana as you would expect
of course we're continuing to improve
the performance and overall reliability
like everything but we've also added
some pretty cool new features as well
which people be able to play it with and
preview for example you'll be able to
set and receive reminders so I could set
a reminder that says remind me to play
Larry and overwatch at 8 o'clock tonight
and wherever Cortana is I'll get that
reminder pretty cool
that sounds great now also your team has
done some work down there in settings
and applying updates explain that to us
yeah so the first thing that we want to
do for folks is make it really clear
when you're getting an update where are
you exactly in the set of sequences so
you're gonna see a new user interface
for that now that'll happen the second
time that you get an update sure of
course you know the first time is when
you're we have to update the update
right that's exactly right so the second
thing that we're gonna do to make
updates easier is we're gonna make it a
lot more obvious for people to get into
a mode where they can update
automatically Scott there's also been
work around accessibility and making
Xbox more approachable for everyone
that's right not only are we making a
continued improvements with the narrator
and magnifier that people are going to
find super useful we've also added a
brand new feature that I'm very excited
about called co-pilot
now copilot allows you to take two
controllers and make them one logical
controller okay so imagine that someone
needs to control their gameplay with a
hand or maybe their chin or a foot or
they need a little bit of extra help
from someone else
and that feature actually works not just
for people that have maybe disabilities
but also people might just need help
getting through their games and we're
pretty cool and what's great as it games
don't have to do anything we handle that
on the system
that's exactly right we make that a
completely seamless thing for
thanks got really exciting stuff the
first batch of creators update features
is arriving today for select Xbox
insider program members if you're an
Xbox insider and don't receive the
updates today hang in there relax
it might take a few weeks but they are
coming more Xbox insiders will receive
the update in the coming weeks and will
steadily release more creators update
features for Xbox one and Windows 10 pcs
leading into the spring Scott thanks for
your time today it's been great I'm
Larry herb Xbox Live's Major Nelson
thanks for watching